in 20 years of being in politics
i have never seen anything like this
the first reaction that i had is when
are there going to be any reinforcements
where is the security in forces
where are the police and there were none
and as the moments went by
you saw it escalate so quickly to the
point where there was
one of the members of the mob sitting in
the speaker's seat
this is unacceptable
we heard what donald trump said what an
hour or so before
those protests began to to unwind uh
he he was encouraging his his supporters
to come here maybe not
encouraging violence direct directly but
what's in his mind at a time
like this when he knows there's so much
anger amongst his own supporters
as i've known him for the last 18 years
donald trump is bloodthirsty he wants to
see blood
spilled in the streets of this country
he wants the chaos he wants the violence
he wants the destruction of property
because he is upset
that he did not win this election that
he did not get us away
and that on january 20th he will no
longer be president of this country
we ask this question so often don't we
is is this the thing that makes him
change tack do you believe
that now what two weeks out from the
inauguration that what we're seeing here
would encourage him to to change
direction to take a different
tone in the message he sends to his
supporters
now donald's not going to change at this
point he is only going to escalate his
rhetoric
he is going to incite more violence and
as nightfall begins to
fall here in the united states you're
going to see
much more violence these protesters
came prepared to fight and that's what
we're witnessing right now donald won't
change in fact
he would not even allow the national
guard to come in and calm the situation
because this is exactly the same that he
wanted
we heard from from mitch mcconnell
unusually uh speaking out against the
president on on the senate floor before
all of this happened
are you surprised that republicans like
him now appear to be sending a very
different message to the president
than they have for the last weeks and
months
you know what surprises me the most is
that they hadn't spoken up
prior to now i mean everyone knows that
donald trump
was trying to you know overturn the
election
and trying to get a result that just
wouldn't come
and so i expected the republicans would
speak up for what was right what was
just
but they remained silent and so here we
are on the 6th of january
and mitch is just starting to speak up
and push back against donald trump
and the the falsehoods that he's been
espousing
and so it's a little too late right now
for that because
things have gotten out of hand right